good afternoon mmm
it is a very great pleasure to welcome
you all this afternoon my name is Maria
Rosa metakaolin I am the I have the
great privilege of directing the Whitney
Humanities Center and the Whitney as
many of you no doubt know hosts all
sorts of notable events throughout the
year and indeed almost every week from
ongoing special screenings of thirty
five-millimeter films this is the campus
thirty-five millimeter projector and
just looking at our website tomorrow
night
Robert Post who is Dean of the law
school will be hosting a screening of
the man who shot Liberty valance by the
way and and commenting on it afterwards
from those screenings to our once a year
Tanner lectures and this past fall as
some of you here know we were treated to
- splendid presentations by the American
composer John Adams and dozens of
student musical performances and faculty
led conferences and art exhibits there's
never a dull or even unhappy moment
around here but for many of us there is
no happier regular occurrence than the
finzi-continis which we have the good
fortune to be able to host every other
year these lectures were established to
honor the memory of Bianca
finzi-continis by her sons the late dr.
Paul Calabrese who we remember this
evening and the Honourable Guido
Calabresi who is here and who for once
plays second fiddle to somebody else
namely his mother and Judge Caleb Daisy
is currently indeed an active judge on
the US Court of Appeals for the Second
Circuit what some people call the Yale
bench and which as many of you know has
recently produced the most the most
recent Supreme Court
justice and before that he was Dean
Calabrese of the Yale Law School most
importantly in our book however he is a
good friend and a loyal supporter of the
work of the Whitney now a number of
years ago the caliber Daisy brothers
thought to honor their mother who was a
native of fit Rada and who had left
fascist Italy to establish herself in
the United States where she became a
scholar and a teacher of French and
Italian literature's and this the
brothers did by establishing a lecture
that would speak to her own lifelong
interests a public lecture of the
broadest possible appeal within our
community for greedo's mother was a
scholar of comparative literature who
taught and published and lectured until
she died at the age of 80 a moment at
which she had just finished a book
infringe on Ernest Hinault and when she
was in fact lecturing in Italy she
believed in literature and in its power
to educate I now quote her son writing
about her literally to lead people out
of themselves and to ennoble and thus
for us the choice of the painted see
Contini lecture always falls back on
that question and that challenge to
celebrate the transformative powers of
literature which is why the roster of
men and women who have spoken in this
series is such a special one which in
recent years has included among others
Orhan Pamuk
before he won his Nobel Prize and indeed
before he was exiled from his beloved
Istanbul about which he spoke when he
spoke in this auditorium and as are
enough easy just two years ago who's
reading Lolita in Tehran is really a
book about the ways in which the reading
of great literature is a defense some
time's the only defense against the
soul-crushing effects of totalitarian
regimes now this afternoon we are
honored and pleased to have as our
special guest Alberto megwin a speaker
who continues in this very special
tradition and who undoubtedly delights
the spirit of Bianca finzi-continis
Alberto Manuel was born in Argentina but
then went on to spend his earliest years
in tel-aviv his father was his country's
first ambassador to Israel and then he
returned to Buenos Aires where as his
fate would have it
his Librarian fate would have it he was
invited by jorge luis borges to become
one of his readers this at a moment when
Manuel was still a teenager but this was
a transformative experience that is
lovingly recounted in his charming book
with Boris in the years since then he
has lived abroad he is a Canadian
citizen who is currently living in
France and he has written a remarkable
number and assortment of books from an
early novel news from a foreign country
came to the most recent collection of
essays entitled a reader reading whose
official publication date I believe is
today and about which one of the first
reviews makes an observation that I
think is particularly apt for this
occasion the reading is often a solitary
activity Manuel reminds us of the
community we join every time we open a
book be it something new or a treasured
volume from our youth indeed the
ever-expanding and delightful library of
migrants own work with volumes in it
such as the extraordinary dictionary of
imaginary places
and a biography of Homer's Iliad and
Odyssey as well as the Luminess library
at night all of this reveals him as a
historian of all that books are about
their writing their reading their
destructions and their salvations his is
a library which celebrates all libraries
personal and communal and today he will
speak on the topic of both his and the
impossibility of writing please join me
in welcoming Alberto megwin
thank you good afternoon I'm especially
delighted and honored to be here first
because invitation came from Maria Rosa
medical who whom I have been reading for
a very long time and who feels quite a
large shelf in my library
when I first gave the title for this
talk
this was quite a while ago I wasn't
quite certain of how I would frame this
this lecture the idea came to me very
recently so I've changed the title and
now the title is the muse of
impossibility if I start I just want to
make two apologies the first is because
I will be quoting more his and I have
had the audacity to translate Borges
into English myself the second and even
more grieve his fault is I will be
quoting Dante and I have a shame
translated act a into English myself one
day in December 1919 the twenty-year-old
jorge luis borges during a short stay in
seville wrote a letter in french to his
friend Maurice Abramovitch in Geneva in
which almost in passing he confesses to
Abramovitch contradictory feelings about
his literary vocation sometimes I think
that it's idiotic to have the ambition
of being a more or less mediocre maker
of phrases but that is my destiny
as Marcus was well aware even then the
history of literature is the history of
this paradox on the one hand the deeply
rooted intuition writers have that the
world exists in Malhar maze much abused
phrase to result in a beautiful book or
as marcus would have it a more or less
mediocre book and on the other hand to
know that the muse governing the
enterprise is as malhomme called her the
muse of importance or to use a freer
translation the muse of impossibility
Milani added later that all who have
ever written anything even those we call
geniuses have attempted this ultimate
book the book with a capital B and all
have failed this double intuition I
think stems from literature itself
somewhere during the time of our first
readings there is a moment in which we
discover that from the ink stains on a
page a world emerges fully fledged and
magically real this is a transformative
experience after which our relationship
to the tangible quotidian world is no
longer the same after having witnessed
the creative capabilities of language
that allows words not merely to
communicate or label but to bring to
life what they label and communicate
that is to say after we have become
readers there can no longer be for us an
innocent perception of the world once
named a thing is no longer itself in the
Platonic sense that Boris would later
delight in a
operating the thing is assumed by the
word that names it contaminated or
enriched by all the ancestry and
connotations and prejudices that the
word drags along in its wake in 1958 and
in a point which I will later return
bought his Road if as the Greek explains
in the crateros the name is archetype of
the thing in the letters of Rose exists
the rose and the entire Nile in the word
Nile
if words in naming the world become the
world become what we know and can know
of the world then surely the reverse is
also true the conviction that haunts
every writer that we can construct or
reconstruct the world through words that
we can utter incoherent syllables
everything that exists and is available
to our senses that we can in effect
accomplish Millar Mays book now this
conviction is an ancient one in the
Jewish tradition it begins appropriately
with Genesis when God presents to Adam
his newly created beasts of the field
and fowl of the air to see what he would
call them and whatsoever Adam called
every living creature that was the name
thereof now consider for a moment this
curious affirmation that God's creation
wants to be whatever Adam called it that
God in an altruistic gesture most
uncommon among authors was allowing
someone else to name his creation
accordingly from then onwards every
creature existed in the name it was
given by Adam and every given name was
implicitly the creature it named leaving
aside the Talmudic debate of whether
Adam invented the names for the animals
or recognized in each animal a
preordained name adam's task established
the basis for the future teachings of
Jewish mysticism for the Kabbalah the
earliest extant kabbalistic texts the
Sepher Yetzirah or book of creation
lends a peculiar prehistory to this
question of names according to the
Sepher Yetzirah God created from the
primal air or engraved upon it the 22
letters of the Hebrew alphabet and all
beings in the three strata of the cosmos
world time and the human body came into
existence through the mere interweaving
of these letters much later on Dante has
a mother version of this story he said
he presents the creation as God creating
the primordial material from which the
other things would be made the angels
and Adam and Eve and afterwards it's the
angels who create the animals and the
plants and so on so in fact when when
Adam names the animals what he's doing
is naming something that had been
created by someone on his level that is
to say the angels
when we get into this afterward now this
divine generosity has its counterpart in
the story of Babel
to curtail human ambition of building a
tower that would reach the heavens
Genesis tells us that God shattered the
single tongue spoken until then by all
humankind into the myriad tongues we
speak today an Adam's prerogative to
name God's creation became undermined or
perhaps enriched by the possibility of
land lending a thing several names to
the Immaculate gift of naming absolutely
was added the corollary that this
absolute singular name the true name for
dog for instance was in fact the
composite of all the names for dog in
all languages Dead or Alive
a monstrous catalogue of synonyms that
somehow encapsulate the essential dog of
the first afternoon in the garden the
perfect name of dog is therefore
available to our intelligence all we
require to utter it is the knowledge of
every language in the universe past
present and future including the speech
of angels according to the Jewish
tradition this absolute name like that
of God himself exists in the combination
of the 22 Hebrew letters and given
enough world and time we should be able
to find it the god-given language of
Adam and his descendants carries both
the promised ability to name the essence
of things
and the near impossibility of doing so
the stories of Adam and of Babel are not
only stories about the magical powers of
words and their confusing multiplicity
they implicitly acknowledge the
existence of these powers and of this
confusion in any single language now
this is something we experience everyday
every time we put something into words
we simultaneously pronounce a
declaration of faith in the power of
language to recreate and communicate our
experience of the world and at the same
time our admission of its shortcomings
to name this experience fully faith in
language is like all true faith and
altered by a practice that contradicts
its claims unaltered in spite of our
knowledge that whenever we try to say
something however simple however
clear-cut only a shadow of that
something travels from our conception to
its utterance and further from its
utterance to its reception and
understanding this will be my excuse as
to why my lecture will be so faltering
every time we say pass the salt we do
indeed convey in essence our request and
also in essence our request is
understood but the shades and echoes of
meaning the private connotations and
cultural roots personal and communal
referential and symbolic emotional and
objective cannot each and every one of
them travel with our words so that those
who hear or read us must reconstruct
this best thing
and upon the core or inside the shell of
those words the universe of sense and
emotion in which they were born Plato
famously suggested that our experience
of the world consisted of nothing but
intimations of meaning and shadows on
the wall of the cave now if that is so
what we put into words are the shadows
of those shadows and every book
confesses the impossibility of holding
on to whatever it is that our experience
seizes all our libraries are the
glorious record of that failure a
failure board has described in a poem
called Ariosto and the Arabs no one can
write a book for a book truly to be you
require the sunset and the dawn
centuries weapons and the cleaving see
gods thaumaturgic gift to Adam and the
PostScript of Babel strangely coexist in
the second commandment of the Decalogue
thou shalt not make unto thee any graven
image or any likeness of anything that
is in the heaven above or what is in the
earth beneath or that which is in the
water under the earth this explicitness
is what Robert Lewis Stevenson haunted
by the words thou shalt not engraved in
Gothic script on the gray stone lintels
of his native edinburgh called
an inverted pleasure the interdiction
that suggests the otherwise unthought-of
sin Stevenson says that when he was
walking through Edinburgh in his youth
he hadn't fought for instance of
sleeping with his neighbor's wife
but there
was the way prohibition fo that's a good
idea so um in this period the second
commandment might read you're able to
create like God Himself the things of
heaven or earth but you are forbidden to
do so so try and we will do our utmost
to prevent it the second commandment
long presented a problem for believers
did God forbid only the creation of
graven images of worship or did his
commandment extend to the creation of
any image any representation any art by
any means whatsoever Psalm 97 in kinds
to the first interpretation and glosses
the prohibition ashamed will be all they
that serve graven images that boast
themselves of things of nought the
celebrated 18th century Hasidic master
rabbi nachman of breslov took the gloss
further the idol he said is destined to
come spit in the face of those who
worship it and put them to shame then
bow before the Holy One blessed be he
and cease to exist but the question of
whether this applies not only to idols
but to any creation still persisted
rabbinical commentators and of course
artists and writers have long pondered
this problem to a certain extent the
history of the human imagination can be
seen as the history of the debate on
this particular interdiction is creation
a permissible endeavour within the human
scope or are we condemned to fail
because all are since it is human and
not divine caring's within it the seeds
of its own failure God says he is a
jealous God in spite of his gift to Adam
is he also a jealous artist
according to an early Talmudic I had
this pistol witty commentary there's a
wonderful book which you probably know
by Lois Ginsberg the legends of the Jews
and it is so full of these wonderful
stories that were built around the
scripture so according to an early
Talmudic commentary the serpent said to
even the garden God himself ate first of
the fruit of the tree and then he
created the world therefore doth he
forbid you to eat thereof lest you
create other worlds because everyone
knows that artisans of the same guild
hate one another one of the most
explicit versions of this paradox is the
18th century legend of the gollum gollum
is a word that first appears in Psalm
139 thine eyes did see my golem a word
which according to the 1st century ad
rabbi L easier means simply an
unarticulated lump something that has
been brought to life but which lacks
proper intelligence now the legend tells
of how the morale of Prague morale being
an acronym of more a new era rabbi Lloyd
our teacher rabbi Lloyd created a
creature out of clay to protect the Jews
from pogroms a monster able to perform
certain tasks but incapable of speaking
on the forehead of the creature
rabbi Lloyd wrote the word amen meaning
truth and this enabled it to come to
life and assist the rabbi in his daily
chores a word allowing something in
inanimate to come to life but the golem
escaped this master's control and
wrought havoc in the ghetto and rabbi
Lloyd was obliged to return it to the
dust by a face
the first letter of a met so that it
read met which means death
the Golan has prestigious ancestors and
of course prestigious descendants from
Frankenstein's monster to terminator and
Robocop and all the rest in a Talmudic
passage of the sanhedrin it is stated
that in the fourth century AD the
Babylonian teacher rava created a man
out of clay and center to rabbi Zahra
who tried to converse with it and when
he saw that the creature could not utter
a single word he said to it you belong
to the spawn of wizards return to the
dust and immediately the creature
crumbled into a shapeless heap another
passage this is a useful one another
passage tells us that in the third
century two Palestinian masters rabbi
Hanina and rabbi o Xie with the help of
the Sepher Yetzirah brought to life a
calf every Shabbat Eve which they then
cooked for dinner these these stories
which bore his quotes are in Gershom
Scholem
book on the Kabbalah inspired by The
Legend of Rabbi Lloyd in 1915 the
Austrian writer Gustav bei rink
published the golem a fantastic novel
about a creature who appears every 33
years at the unreachable window of a
circular room without doors deep in the
Prague ghetto now that same year 1915
the adolescent bought his trapped with
his family in Switzerland during the war
red may Rings Gollum in German and was
enthralled by its haunting atmosphere
everything in the book is uncanny he
would later write even the mono
syllables of the table of con
tens park punch nah spoke leashed bore
his saw in my rings baalam a fiction
made up of dreams that enclose other
dreams something that carried in its
very dreamlike imagining the admission
of its own unreality more than 40 years
later in 1957 more has included a
description of the golem in the first
version of the book of imaginary beings
and a year later he told the story of
rabbi Lloyd in what was to become one of
his most famous poems which was first
published in the Jewish magazine devar
and in the winter of this was in the
winter of 1958 and then afterwards board
has published it in his personal and
follow tree placing it before a short
text entitled excuse me Inferno 1:32
this positioning is is interesting
because the text on Dante's Inferno
considers from a different perspective
the same question which is in the
garland poem Borya says rabbi Lloyd
wonder why he was driven to fashion this
apprentice of man and what might be the
meaning of his creature and in the text
on Dante's Inferno both the Panther the
beginning of the commedia and then the
dying poet himself learn and afterwards
forget why it is that they have been
created more hisses garland poem ends
with his court rain in the hour of
anguish and dim light the rabbi looked
in all upon his Gollum who will tell us
what was felt by God looking upon his
own rabbi in Prague
like the ancient biblical commentators
Bohr has pondered again and again these
fundamental questions what are the
limits of creation to what success can
an artist aspire
how can writers achieve their purpose
when all they have at their disposal is
the imperfect tool of language and above
all what is created when an artist sets
out to create does a new world come into
being or is a dark mirror of the word
lifted up for us to gaze in Bohr has
disbelieved in realism and psychological
fiction for him the world made out of
words was the world but is the world a
work of art of lasting reality or is it
an imperfect golem is it a lie or a
handful of lifeless dust and finally
even if the were and answer to these
questions can we know it Bork is often
quoted Kafka's unappealable dictum if it
had been possible to build the Tower of
Babel without climbing it it would have
been allowed borkus died in Geneva at
7:47 a.m. on June 14th 1986
Borges had often spoken of Geneva as my
other homeland as a special favor the
admitted Administrative Council of
Geneva decided to grant his widow
permission to have him buried in the
cemetery of plan pal a reserved for the
great and famous Swiss in memory of
Marcus's grandmother's one Catholic and
the other Protestant the service was
read by both father Pierre Jacky and by
pastor ed
the mo Mowlam pastor mom will answer
dress judiciously opened with the first
verse from the Gospel of John in the
beginning was the word bore his said
pastor Mon Moulin was a man who
unceasingly searched for the right word
the term that would sum up the whole the
the final meaning of things and went on
to explain that as the good book taught
us a man can never reach that word by
his own efforts glossing John's verses
it is not a writer who discovers the
word but the word that reaches the
writer pastor Mon Moulin summed up his
own version of borghese's literary credo
that the rightest task is to find the
right words to name the world knowing
all the while that these words are as
words unreachable without what we must
call grace granted by the Holy Spirit
the muse or as boring as himself said
what the sad mythology of our time calls
the unconscious here the Christian view
rejoins that of its Jewish ancestors
words are our only tools to lend and
recover meaning and at the same time
that they allow us to discern that
meaning they show us that even when
grace allows a glimpse of that meaning
it lies precisely beyond our reach
beyond the pale of words just on the
other side of language
medieval reparation systematize these
two components the craft of words and
their possible accomplishment they
stressed the distinction between grammar
that is to say the rules and limitations
of language as a tool and poetry the
rules and limitations of language
applied though most scholars discuss the
first of these elements grammar a number
mainly in France studied its application
in the work of up Taurus such as Virgil
whose literature existed in the peculiar
tension between the correct use of
language and the individual imagination
or invention hue of saint-victor in the
12th century noted that the question
could be applied to all creative arts he
wrote to separate concerns are to be
recognized and distinguished in every
art first how one ought to treat the art
itself and second how one ought to apply
the principles of that art in all other
matters whatsoever
so the first enquired into the qualities
and capabilities of language and the
second into its Gollum like results
these notions and the questions they
elicit are almost universal and I I
don't mean to compile a trite list of
intellectual coincidences but it is a
fact that the fundamental paradox of
language is apparent in almost every
culture in Islamic thought the letters
of the alphabet have an independent
divinely decreed will effected before
pen is put to paper and over which the
scribe has no control in the 16th
century Tulsi das the greatest of Hindu
poets argued that the reality of fiction
is always other than the reality of the
material world
world and overrides it in Zen Buddhism
the instantaneous illumination or
Sartori is always both within and beyond
the grasp of words so in all these cases
as of course in the judeo-christian
tradition the rightest impossibilities
appear to be essentially two to conceive
properly and to put properly the concept
into words the writer's craft is
therefore twice constrained by the
limits of imagination which require
faith to provide the evidence of things
not seen as st. Paul had it and by the
limits of language which require writers
to rely on what Coleridge called the
willing suspension of disbelief of their
readers and listeners all his life
bought his explored and tried out these
implacable truth from his very first
readings and when Osiris to the final
writings dictated on his deathbed in
Geneva every text became in his mind of
the literary paradox of being named with
without ever quite naming ever since his
adolescence something in every book he
read seemed to escape him like a wayward
monster promising nevertheless
a further page a greater epiphany at the
next reading
and something in every page he wrote
forced him to confess that the author
was not the ultimate master of his own
creation poetry he argued in 1972 is in
the commerce of the poem with the reader
not in the series of symbols registered
on the pages of a book this double bind
the promise of Revelation that every
book grants its reader and the warning
of the fee that every books every book
gives its writer lens the literary act
it's constant fluidity and of the many
books in which war has found
confirmation of these intuitions none
served him better than the one he called
perhaps the greatest literary work ever
written the Dante's Divine Comedy Dante
is essential to the understanding of
barkis's relationship to language his
acquaintance with Dante's you probably
know took place Midway his own road of
life when he turned 40 from the last
month of 1939 to early month of the
following year during his streetcar ride
to and from his dreary job a sub
librarian at the McGill can a municipal
librarian when ascites bore his read
Dante's Divine Comedy helped until I
reached purgatory he wrote in his
autobiography by John Aitken Carlisle's
prose translation after that I continued
the ascent of my own
the dentist poem never left him John
team has established a sort of annotated
catalogue of the many texts by Borges
that allude or are inspired by the
commedia and Maria Rosa Meno Cal has
explored in depth the most famous of or
hisses Dante story the aleph to show his
ambivalent relationship to its shadows I
find it intensely moving that Dante was
with Borges at his very end
one of Marcus's last projects which he
never realized was to write a short
story set in Venice in which Dante tries
to imagine a sequel to his commedia to
his reading of Dante bought his
counterpoint at his reading of Kafka
whom he had discovered a few years
earlier for Kafka following the Talmudic
commentators and the Hasidic masters the
task of the writer is not to accept the
divine verdict but to negotiate with God
to find convincing arguments that will
allow the writer to create knowing that
the result no matter how great the
effort or the talent will always be a
golem for Dante following the medieval
reading of Aristotle and above all of
Aquinas the poet in certain moments of
inexplicable grace is commanded by love
to write as Dante says in his dialogue
in purgatory with the poet bonagiunta
since love is the divine force that
moves everything even the universe
itself to stress this later in Paradise
Dante will echo a verse from the 45th
Psalm my tongue is the pen of a ready
scribe and reaffirm his obedience to
this dictating force asking
his readers asking us to bear witness
that he has done his best to put into
words what has been commanded to his
poetic intellect here is your food for I
can do no more because the matter of
which I have been made scribe now draws
to its own self all of my care and yet
even then in this god-given moment of
grace the poet's best is not enough
having reached the top of Mount
purgatory after crossing into the Garden
of Eden when Beatrice finally turns her
unveiled Christ laden eyes towards Dante
he has to confess that no one no poet
however favoured by the muses can
possibly express what he's shown so
clearly in the splendor of eternal
Living Light even at that instant of
illumination human memory and human
language fall short of telling the truth
a truth revealed only in part since no
creature can know God's enormous truth
in its fullness and over and over
throughout his journey from the dark
forest to the Godhead itself
Dante cries out that what he has been
commanded to say is ineffable since it
is the fate of every artist to stop
before the uttermost reach but now it's
best that I put here an end to pursuing
her beauty writing verse as every artist
must reaching his last now of course
another choice an artist has in order to
justify not fulfilling what Grace has
dictated is to die but Borges has a
wonderful little book on a poet he much
admired in his youth and then he much
criticized Leopoldo warnings
um it was written with Bettina level
work and it's a biography of lagunas and
analysis of his work but certainly the
last chapter was written by Borges
himself and it describes lagunes
deciding to commit suicide and what his
has a paragraph in this where he
describes luan is taking the train to
Tigre where he's going to shoot himself
and looking out of the window and seeing
the sky and the trees and the stars and
thinking I don't have to put this into
words anymore I'm going to kill myself
so I don't need to try and pursue this
arduous task of transferring this which
is given to me in the words I don't have
to do it anymore
but that is perhaps too drastic Valerie
was to sum up dentists lament in one
line
the poem is never completed only
abandoned borkus agreed for him the
tragedy of the commedia is Advanta
attempted and failed to create a
universe of words in which the poet is
absolute master a world in which he
might enjoy the love of his adored by
3qi converse with his beloved virgil
renew his relationship with absent
friends reward with a place in heaven
those he deemed worthy of reward and
take revenge on his enemies by
condemning them to hell the ancient
dictum nomina soon consequently ariram
words are the fruit of things should
work both ways he thought if words exist
because they correspond to existing
things then things might exist because
there are words to name them for Dante
for Borges this must be the poet's credo
and yet each literary work and trusts to
his writer the form that it is seeking
or his wrote in the preface to Lacan who
Talos and trusts he wrote he could have
written commands he could also have
added that no poet not even Dante can
fully accomplished the command for
bordick is the Camellia that most
perfect of human literary endeavors was
nevertheless a failed creation because
it failed to become that rhetorical
archetype invented by Aquinas what the
author intended the word that gives life
both Borges and Dante realized is alas
not equivalent to the living creature
that who speaks the word the word that
remains on the page the word that while
imitating life is incapable of being
live Plato made Socrates decry the
creations of artists and poets for that
very reason because art is imitation
never the real thing if success were
possible and it isn't the universe would
become redundant several tags by Borges
described this resolution among them the
long story of the Congress in which a
man sets out to compile an encyclopedia
of the universe and realizes in the end
that he can't do it and that the
Encyclopedia already exists and is the
world itself and it was wonderful last
scene he goes through the city of Buenos
Aires and admires everything as if it
were his own creation his own
encyclopedic also in the parable of the
palace in which a Chinese emperor shows
a poet his extraordinary palatial estate
with its many buildings and gardens and
the poet then composes a short poem in
which the whole Palace is ensnared at
which point the palace disappears
because no two identical things can
occupy the same space in the universe
one must always be lost whether because
of the imperfection of our tools or the
imperfection of ourselves whether
because of the jealousy of the Godhead
or his concern with our indulging in
redundant tasks the ancient prohibition
of the Decalogue continues to serve as
warning and as in citement the dusty and
unsatisfactory golem that still haunts
our dreams through the alleyways of
Prague is after all the highest
achievement to which our crafts can
aspire bringing dust to life and have it
do our bidding
however clumsily however dangerously
when the Weitzman Institute at revolt
built its first computer Gershom Scholem
suggested that it be named golem one our
creations are at best something that
suggests an approximation to a copy of a
blurry intuition of the real thing
itself an imperfect imitation of an
ineffable archetype this achievement is
our unique and humble prerogative the
only art that is synonymous with reality
is that of God gazing upon the pathway
to Eden sculpted by God himself in the
purgatory of the proud Dante says that
he saw not better than I saw who saw
these scenes in real life because God's
reality in God's representation of
reality are identical ours are not now
let me briefly touch on a few of boris's
takes it illustrate these questions and
I leave aside one of the great porgies
Ian devices to avoid the whole problem
which is simply don't write the book
what he said to imagine a story is a
wonderful experience but to actually
write the novel is an exaggeration
so what what he did as you know is write
reviews of inexistent books write the
commentaries write preface --is and so
on of books that need not be written
because what counted was the reading as
would be creators as poets sometimes the
result of our best Labor's fills us with
shame one of Marcus's most celebrated
texts to which he gave the English title
dream Tigers tells of war his dreaming
and realizing that he is dreaming and
since in the state of semi-consciousness
he can do what he wants we are the
masters of our dreams he decides to
dream a tiger he was in love with Tigers
so he wanted to dream a real tiger in
all its regal and savage glory but even
in dreams the dreamer cannot achieve his
purpose the tiger appears
Borka says but shriveled up or rickety
or with impure variations of shape or of
and inadmissible size or far too
fleeting or looking more like a dog or
like a bird this is in translatable but
he says dear ando a better or Pajero the
end or tending towards you cannot
translate it more less like looking more
like a dog or like a bird
sometimes the failure of our craft
allows us to understand our own
imperfect nature as embark as a story
the circular ruins in which a Magus
dreams a man into being only to realize
that he too is a dream or in everything
and nothing of beautiful short texts
were Shakespeare after his death us God
to restore to him his own unique
identity
I says Shakespeare to God who have been
in vain so many men want to be only one
and myself to which God's voice answers
from a whirlwind neither I am I I dreamt
the world as you dreamt your work my
Shakespeare and among the shapes of my
dream there
you who like myself is many and no one
just one more this particular theme is
made explicit in the conclusion of the
story the search of other Roy's now in
Spanish is la boqueria Roy's which is
the search for Averroes and the search
of other Roy's and Boris uses the word
mooska because he hated the word
buscetta he said mmm a beautiful title
Nabokov Ave Viva no anyway it's called a
book that Elroy's in this story bought
his rights I wish to tell the process of
the defeat first I recall that
Archbishop of Canterbury who decided to
demonstrate the existence of God then
the alchemists who sought the
Philosopher's Stone
then those who vainly attempted to
trisect the right angle and to square
the circle later I thought that more
poetic was the case of a man who intends
a goal that is not denied to others but
only to him and I recalled other Roy's
who locked within the scone finds of
Islam could never have known the meaning
of the words tragedy and comedy I told
the story and as I went further I felt
that what the God mentioned by Burton
must have felt who wanted to create a
ball and created a Buffalo I felt that
my work was mocking me
I felt that other Roy's trying to
imagine what a drama was without having
an inkling of what a theater might have
been was not more absurd than me trying
to imagine other Roy's without anything
more than a few crumbs of rain on Lane
and I seen palacios I felt on the last
page that my story was a symbol of the
man I was while I was writing it and
that in order to put my story into words
I had to be that man and that in order
to be
that man I had to write the story and so
on into infinity the moment I stopped
believing in him other Roy's disappears
so it is that the writer who imagines a
man and is only capable of putting him
into words as a poor golem is himself
made to play the role of the golem
imperfectly created and capable only of
imperfection and incompetent creature
casting in turn blasphemous doubts on
the competence of his maker in this game
of shifting mirrors the faulty golem
becomes our modest faulty all-embracing
literature and literature becomes the
golem destined to fall to dust yes more
his might answer and havedo would call
it Paul when I would add or dust but
dust in love yes what Boris would say
but an immortal golem because even when
the first letter of the writing on its
forehead is a face then M it becomes met
a word still stands to name for us yet
another unnameable death itself the end
of all creation in this sense the end is
not an act of destruction but the
recognition of the construction that
precedes it
our purpose in life wrote Stevenson is
not to could succeed but to continue to
fail in the best of spirits failure then
as writers understand it it's not just
the only possible outcome of a literary
endeavor but its goal its supreme
achievement distinguishing between the
classical narrative in which the hero
reaches his objective like Jason winning
the Golden Fleece and the modern one in
which K never reaches the castle what
his observe that in the latter case the
very fact of not attaining the desired
objective of the adventure remaining
apparently unfinished is not a weakness
of the author's imagination but on the
contrary its strength and purpose Dante
in the first verses of Paradiso notes
that precisely when we find ourselves on
the verge of attaining the desired
quarry our intellect sink so deep that
memory cannot go back that is to say
when poets come close to reaching their
imagined goal then articulation of what
that ideal form is must fail and memory
of what it was must faulter every work
of art every work of literature that
offers an always receding horizon of
comprehension that allows us to call it
great is in the sense incomplete because
it must allow for the questions about
its essence to remain open and the
intuition of its whole to be uncertain
it must admit cracks and crevices in
which the reader can protract the limits
of interpretation and exploration
the mortal conclusions of epic let tails
never put an end to the eternal battles
in which their heroes engage the
tragedies of Oedipus and Orestes remain
ultimately unresolved after colonist and
Delphi Hamlet's father and Banquo's
ghost continue to roam in our imagined
air unappeased after the death of their
opposing protagonists Dickens's happy
endings are endure abaut because they
stand on immediate unresolved characters
continue their quest long after the book
is closed
the only absolute conclusions are those
of the stories made up of nothing but
surface narratives without width or
depth perfectly crafted and sterile
objects of consumption that crowd the
bestseller tables in the bookstores
stupidity noted flow Barre is the desire
to conclude utopian models of the world
and statistical charts that measure our
reality have an appeasing neatness about
them in literature however things don't
work out that way literature follows
rules that overrides the rules of
fantasy and the rules of reality
literature is neither wishful thinking
no documentary science
neither Arcadian illusion nor catechist
t'k Dogma in spite of Dante's desire
their treatise bore his points out in a
masterly essay escapes Dante in the end
following the poems overruling logic
Virgil the source of Dante's craft must
prove to be fallible friends and enemies
may sometimes occupy unexpected places
in the eternal afterlife and even the
poem itself the meticulous astonishing
and lightened and enlightening coma
eeeh must finally self-destruct in the
end words must fail Dante refused to
bear witness to the ultimate glory leave
the reader dazzled by the closing light
when will and desire turn over like an
even keeled wheel and with the wordless
knowledge that whatever this crowning
revelation was and is it also moves the
Sun and the other stars and that is all
we know and as always even in the case
of such a triumphant clothe the very use
of similes and metaphors confesses the
defeat of literature we must compare
because we cannot say the most which we
can aspires readers is that
inexpressible epiphany were high fantasy
loses its power this is the epiphany
that bore his memorably put into words
in the wall and the books small
beautiful text he speaks of the
imminence of a revelation that does not
take place that that the thrill of art
that the aesthetic experience is the
imminence of a revelation that does not
take place let constant expectation must
be our sole reward so we are never to
see it fulfilled
I'm going to end with this the lecture
you have been reckless enough to ask me
to deliver this evening here is the name
of one of the great families in 20
century Italian literature in Georgia
bersani's novel the garden of the
finzi-continis ends with exactly the
same resigned exultation the same
recognition of the fact that in spite of
knowing that even high fantasy will not
succeed in bringing to life what even
memory cannot fully rescue we must
continue to exercise the enfeebles of
language of words as pezzini's narrator
says of everyday deceiving and desperate
words and he adds let these words and no
others put here a seal on that small
portion which the heart has been able to
recall small or large as that portion
might be we cannot do more we live in
the grip of this immemorial and
contradictory injunction on the one hand
not to build things that might lead to
idolatry and complacency on the other to
build things worthy of memory to to put
into verse as Dantas says things that
are hard to conceive well in biblical
terms this means rejecting the Serpent's
temptation to aspire to be gods but also
to reflect God's creation back to him in
luminous pages that conjure up his world
in rationalistic terms to accept that
the limits of human creation are
hopelessly unlike the limitless creation
of the cosmos and yet to strive
continuously to attain those limits by
making full use of our gifts this is the
paradox of all our arts and crafts
performed under the grinning watch of
the muse of impossibility between these
two mandates we exist
like golems in this often miserable and
sometimes blissful and always privileged
human condition thank you very much